in this scene from mission impossible
fallout
ethan hunt jumps 25 000
feet out of a plane before landing in
paris
a risky move like this would normally
require a stunt double
but that's actually tom cruise and that
background behind him
is not a green screen the actor is
famous for almost always doing his own
stunts
no matter how dangerous from climbing
the world's tallest building
to hanging off the side of a plane to
pulling off perhaps one of the most
dangerous helicopter chases
ever captured on film cruise is always
finding new ways to top himself
and he's not stopping anytime soon
at more than 2 700 feet the burj khalifa
in dubai is the world's
tallest building so it was only a matter
of time before crews decided to climb it
for this stunt the actor had to climb
1700 feet in the air
so he had to wear a special harness
attached to strategic points in the
building
to do this the crew needed to break 26
different windows
with permission of course this harness
was so
tight crews said it cut off his
circulation the 65 millimeter imax
cameras and additional helicopters
shooting the scene
only had a limited amount of time to
record so they had to move fast
but cruz wasn't just climbing the
building he also had to
fall four stories and run down the
surface of the building in a move known
as an australian repel
all of this required a lot of
preparation crews practiced by climbing
up a
makeshift glass wall heated with
artificial lights
to replicate the hot temperature of the
windows on the burj khalifa
stunt coordinator greg smurs estimated
that crews and the crew put in at least
200 hours of rehearsal time this isn't
cruz's first experience climbing however
in 2000's mission impossible 2 he
climbed a 2
000 foot cliff in utah attached to
nothing but a thin
safety rope and had to jump 15 feet from
one cliff to another
the stunts in edge of tomorrow were
tough but it was actually the costume
that made it even more so
throughout the film cruz's character
wears metal exoskeleton armor
something that typically might be added
on through cgi but cruz wore a real suit
sometimes for up to six hours a day
straight
one version weighed 85 pounds and
another version weighed around 130
pounds
thanks to a sniper rifle and missile
launcher on the back
here's what cruz normally looks like
running in a scene
compare that to this shot of him and his
co-star emily blunt
running while both wore the suits in
another stunt for the film
the actor was attached to a wire and
thrown across the room while wearing it
to take some of the weight off and help
them run more easily
cruise and blunt were often attached to
cables it took crews
30 minutes to get into the suit and 30
to get out
the team eventually got that down to
around 30 seconds
[Music]
well cruz had plenty of experience
flying planes in top gun
in rogue nation he decided to go into
the air in a rather unconventional
and more terrifying way for the film's
opening scene he had to cling onto the
side of an airbus
a400m that took him up a thousand feet
at a speed of a hundred knots for six to
eight minutes
the plane took off did a complete
circuit and
landed all with tom cruise secured to
the side with this wire that would later
be erased in post-production
because the plane went so high into the
air crews had to wear
special contacts to protect his eyes
from flying debris
and strong gusts of wind plus the crew
had to make sure takeoff conditions
were absolutely clear if they ran into
even
a single bird or some rocks on the
runway it could severely injure the
actor
the stunt had to be performed over and
over again until the actor director and
crew
felt they got it right for cruz he
didn't feel confident in the take until
he had gone up eight times
[Music]
the fifth mission entry contained not
one but two death-defying stunts
this one involving military-style
preparation
in the film ethan hunt needs to open an
underwater vault
the vault itself was created using cgi
but cruz still needed to work underwater
for the sequence
which clocks in at just about six
minutes long
he started by jumping off a 120 foot
ledge into a tank filled 20 feet high
with water
then crews needed to film takes while
holding his breath
for four to six minutes according to
cruz most
underwater sequences might have an actor
hold their breath for up to 10 seconds
so this was definitely a challenge he
trained with free diving expert
kirk crack on a breath hold special
operations program designed for military
personnel
part of his training involved breathing
exercises that would lower his standard
heart rate
essentially training his body to use
less oxygen
and he wouldn't just be sitting in the
water during the shoot he would be
swimming around
why so long well they had just 10 days
to film the sequence
so director christopher mcqueary shot in
a series of continuous takes
meaning the actor couldn't easily pop up
for air
[Music]
while cruz hasn't gone to space yet he
has performed a zero gravity stunt
in the mummy he had to hold his breath
underwater yet again
dodge explosions and even fight russell
crowe
the biggest standout stunt was this
sequence in which a cargo plane
plummets to the ground crews was offered
the chance to shoot it on a sound stage
but he declined and opted for the real
thing
to imitate the experience of the crash
where the characters float up into the
air
they shot on a plane that nasa typically
uses to train
astronauts they decked out the inside of
the plane with padding
to make it look like a real cargo plane
the plane couldn't go into zero gravity
mode
until it was at about 25 000 feet once
at that position it would free
fall for 22 seconds during that time
crews endured
four high altitude flights the sequence
was eventually wrapped after a
whopping 64 tapes and while cruz's
stunts usually require a lot of
rehearsal
the actor actually said that that was
quite tough here as floating in the air
makes things unpredictable
cruz has flown a plane and hung onto the
side of one
but for fallout he also learned to fly a
helicopter as part of an aerial chase
sequence
the 2018 film contains an array of the
actors most daring stunts
like this motorcycle chase in which the
actor rode through the streets of paris
sometimes at 100 miles per hour for the
helicopter chase
even hunt flies through dangerous
mountain terrain to stop a nuclear bomb
before shooting crews worked 16 hours a
day
to hit the required 2 000 hours of
helicopter training
there would be up to 13 helicopters
close to each other in the sky at once
so crews and the stunt team carefully
planned out every little move in advance
using these toy helicopters and the
actor needed all the preparation he
could get
as he would be acting piloting and
operating the cameras mounted to the
front of his chopper
all at the same time all that planning
was crucial
particularly for this 360 degree
corkscrew dive
a move that's challenging even for
professional pilots
according to matt evans an instructor at
the school where crews trained
the stunt involves starting with a
descent rolling into a turn
and then holding the turn as you go down
while that's happening
the actor can never take his hands off
the controls
[Music]
in mission impossible 2 cruz's character
jumps out of a helicopter
but that scene was shot using a green
screen in fallout cruz decided to
actually jump out of a plane and became
the first actor to do a halo jump on
camera halo stands for high altitude
low opening he jumped from a height of
over 25
000 feet but didn't open his parachute
until he was below
2000 feet this military move allows a
soldier to jump into battle undetected
the actor practiced in a giant wind
tunnel constructed on the set
and then according to stunt coordinator
wade eastwood jumped out of a plane
around a hundred times and a trained
stunt camera operator
also had to jump out of the plane with
cruz to get the shot
to make sure every facial expression was
still visible on camera
the crew developed a special helmet for
crews with a light in it
allowing him to breathe properly while
falling
in the long-awaited sequel to tom
cruise's 1986 breakout film
cruz is back in the cockpit of a fighter
plane
the film was shot on real military
aircraft carriers
and crews flew in real planes a new
camera system
allowed the crew to put six imax quality
cameras inside the cockpit
in the original top gun one of the f-14s
had
three cameras total mounted onto it but
it wasn't just crews going solo
the rest of the cast trained alongside
him cruz and the rest of the cast
needed to actually fly for an even
better viewing experience
despite the potential risks there are
aspects of flying one
simply couldn't see if they used green
screen like these distortions in the
face
what's your favorite tom cruise stunt
let us know in the comments
[Music]
you